oh mon dieu il a fallu près de 75 ans
pour que le sac du soldat politicienne
saint-laurent reviennent à montréal et
se retrouvent entre les mains de sa
fille francine il en parlait pas
beaucoup parce que il ya eu il était il
était témoin de choses de 5 vraiment
terrible et quand il est décédé je me
suis dit bon de voir un peu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans son histoire une
attente de 25 ans étaient nécessaires
après son décès pour avoir accès au
dossier militaire de son père natif de
mont joli qui a fait une partie de la
campagne d'italie contre l'armée
allemande en 1944
mon père est décédé en 1993 ça veut dire
qu'il fallait que j'attende jusqu'en
2018 pour faire le demande mais j'ai été
patient et j'ai oublié chemin j'avais
toujours le petit note je disais
d'andrest pintal reste quinze ans pour
découvrir l'histoire de paul etienne
c'est laurent il a fallu que deux
événements arrivent simultanément à
l'été 2010 8
d'abord la demande déposée à
bibliothèque et archives canada par sa
fille et dans une grange isolé des
montagnes de toscane la trouvaille d'un
jeune italien intéressés par les objets
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
un vieux sac à dos bleu monsieur du
couteau
il chauffe c'est loeb depuis le teint de
mon passage de la tht et puis et c'est
ce qu'on peut la voir et du ben moi
juste en train de pourrir le prenez le
lot lorenzo cam pouces échanges alors
avec des collectionneurs sur le web qui
l'orientent vers le canada a donné le
jeune homme contact des journalistes de
siby ci qui s'adresse à bibliothèque et
archives canada l'organisme vient tout
juste de recevoir la demande de la fille
du soldat saint laurent
c'est vraiment numéro 10 mètres cubes de
mon père just et reconnaissante
francine c'est laurent s'est empressé
d'écrire à lorenzo si le jeune homme
n'avait pas fait toutes ses recherches
elle l'ignoreraient l'existence même du
sac à dos que son père
a dû abandonner le sac est un comme un
amuse gueule de tout une fabuleuse
histoire derrière ça c'est finalement au
musée de la citadelle de québec que se
retrouvera le sac à dos dès la semaine
prochaine les sacs de seconde guerre
mondiale il y en a dans les collections
y en a chez les collectionneurs
cependant d'en trouver en comme ça
identifié un soldat on est en mesure de
compléter le numéro de matricule
confirmé que c'est un membre du royal
22e régiment
il y avait tout laissé il avait rien que
ça un sac à dos et se sont battus pour
que nous puissions penser librement un
combat et un sac qui ne seront pas
oubliés en italie et au canada
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal